what has gone on since like we started
there's a lot [ __ ] soldiers always been
doing a lot
oh yeah dude that shit's so funny I
watched so this morning when I couldn't
sleep I watched the entirety of soldier
boy's Breakfast Club interview and that
dude is like weirdly charismatic yeah
wait like just listening to I was upset
when it was over yeah I was like for
some reason now I'm on this dude's side
he is just absolutely like demonized
himself on social media and like made
himself a joke a little bit over the
past four or five years right leg he
should be a [ __ ] icon he should be
yeah and that's what he's trying to do I
think he's trying like reclaim his like
icon status right you know regardless of
what you want to say about crank dad and
how like corny it is or whatever kind of
was [ __ ] an anthem I mean it wasn't
kind of it was yeah that [ __ ] like
pioneered [ __ ] weird hip-hop I mean
dude just this whole story about music
yeah I'm just how his whole story of how
he blew up and everything about Soulja
really is is it should [ __ ] inspire
you like whether or not you like the
song yeah you can't deny what he did was
[ __ ] I'm it was incredible yeah yeah
so it it sucks and I and I also I also
wonder if he feels like you know does he
feel like maybe he made a few missteps
like in in that success he should did
other things and now he's like I [ __ ]
up so he's like trying to not only like
gain his throne back but like I feel
like there's a financial motivation like
[ __ ] like like I should have should have
like planned better my money and and and
got the bag while I should have now cuz
he's still getting pretty yeah I mean
yeah he definitely like he says in the
interview he regrets not like signing
people that he like thinks he put on he
was like he's going on and on about how
he think he was the first person that
flew me goes out to LA and they stayed
at his crib and then they signed with
someone else right and he like didn't
have his record label up and going so he
like would just put people on and then
just like sit back and what this is what
he says he can't like when he's talking
I believed him because he's like
charismatic and weirdly when he ran s
odmg like the story that jumps out at me
is the
john-boy now yeah john-boy was like like
a artist that he had signed and they had
this whole beef where basically it
signed a SL dmg and like soldier just
did nothing for him that was his side of
the story it's any dish done to go be
with GPE within gb obviously went
nowhere
but he liked try to get on the wave with
chief keef it's dude it I mean some of
the shitty was things like he's like
yeah I mean I mean all the me goes
earliest music videos like the one that
blew them the ones that blew them up hmm
and he is and he [ __ ] the Versace B
was his with soldier boys he wrapped
over that like a year earlier oh really
yeah it was on YouTube it's still on
YouTube and then he goes took it because
I guess Zaytoven gave him the same beat
so they let me go set him up and was
like yo man we didn't know blah blah
blah and he's like whatever just fine
just use it damn because I'm saying like
it's weird he has I guess his hands and
all these different things there's
[ __ ] there's a drake stole a bar from
him yeah this [ __ ] like that on my
washington's oh my god damn dude why why
does everyone think you're such a joke
like this shouldn't we shouldn't be a
thing he's you you know I'm saying I
mean immediately selling Chinese
products so much they told him not to do
that like someone really justification
that was so funny to look he like he
brings the [ __ ] thing he's like yeah
I got the soldier console right here he
opens it up it's like does and you know
it looks like a [ __ ] knock off we
like it looks exactly the same
yeah and he's like man no one gave no
one gave Steve Jobs [ __ ] when he started
doing his thing no one gave Bill Gates
[ __ ] why cuz they white like no but
you're not made like he had people
manufacturing these device designing and
manufacturing devices for all you're
doing is drop shipping Chinese consoles
that are made by someone else you say
iPhones made in China they make that
[ __ ] for 18 bucks they sell it for a
thousand I'm I getting [ __ ] it's not
that as logic is off but it's like you
know it is off dude it's very off I mean
it's it's okay how can i how can I be
unsolvable
sigh dear reasonably I'm just saying
that I get where he's coming from like
it's fair to say although things are
made somewhere else and then sold at a
higher margin sure like I can agree with
that but to your point you're it's -
you're not like a tech entrepreneur like
will.i.am tried it yeah [ __ ] yourself
yeah and he did it the right way I'm
just saying if we wanted to start a
company and sell the exact same console
soldier boys we could do that easily
they wanted to start a company and sell
iPhones we couldn't do that because
Apple has designed yeah manufactured the
iPhone themselves yeah just as every
other like real tech entrepreneur has I
don't know man I feel like my soldier
boy just branded himself as like one of
these dudes online that just sells [ __ ]
and sells their courses on how to sell
[ __ ] online then to be yeah that's fine
yeah that's totally fine but like don't
act like you're like a the next like
tech billionaire I just think it's such
a weird move man that like it can only
that's like the a weirder version of
like just starting up like a cash app
link yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like for
him to be like oh they sell it for a
thousand it's like okay you're you're
very like clearly you're saying like
yeah I'm making a killing off it [ __ ] I
mean he showed [ __ ] Charlemagne his
spot or his Shopify I think it was a
shop before I don't know why but he was
like look at this it said it yesterday
made 250 grand off yeah man I don't know
if it's fake or not but like wow what
else we be Wow
who knows man who really knows notice
how much shit's going through that
Shopify you know who say it's man
laundering money through his own maybe
he's a money-laundering scheme yeah
maybe were just all hideous and we just
don't know what's going on behind the
scenes I mean one of the craziest things
that he said that that I didn't realize
was that he so he produced crank that
but like in doing so he got to keep a
hundred percent of the royalties which
was seven million dollars in one year
and saying how [ __ ] crazy is that
[ __ ] just why so rich and
give it to a financial adviser never rap
again yeah I'm done bro it's kind of
what do you I mean so he should've did
as he made like you know ever since like
kiss me through the phone and turn my
swag on and [ __ ] like that he hasn't
really made any music that's like yeah
that has mainstream appeal that's
actually true and I can't remember the
last project he put out so damn dude
yeah you know what he did definitely
like kick off that whole like ringtone
rapper yeah yeah I mean that wasn't like
like half the royalties were in
ringtones yeah and and that was like a
ringtone rapper I think is now what we
call like or like how the social
equivalent of like a soundcloud rapper
yeah you know doing it yourself or like
yeah whatever man yeah I mean you can't
deny what he's [ __ ] done in rap and
for rap that's crazy man I don't know
why he's like doing this weird like
press run though cuz he was on whatever
show academics is on I did sucks by the
way yeah I think they're I think they're
just everyday struggle yeah I think I
think they're just trying to capitalize
on the story you're not turning it down
yeah yeah I think that's all it is
like they just see him like going crazy
on live like you'll we need to get a
soldier in here this is a hot topic yeah
it's so you see our clip on flat TV
where he's talking about how like you
know he shot somebody yeah he talks
about that on there yeah it's like he
does [ __ ] like that what I think that's
the stuff that like over time is like
eroded like what people like really
liked about him because you think it
didn't happen how dude that story is so
like convoluted that's what I was
thinking when I'm listening to this I'm
like but every time someone asked a
question he has an answer and it's like
are you making this up as you go or and
then he goes and then he goes yeah man I
got a movie coming out in in may AMC
Theaters sold his story I tell the I
tell it I tell like every detail of what
happened during that thing yeah and he
keeps plugging this movie and it's like
is the movie even real reason why you
keep plugging hams and heaters why is it
only coming out of names in theatres
just like some local releases yeah like
I don't know is this story real to begin
with flex take your vision notion break
that's not a flex